je suis arrivée donc de mes 10 ans
jusqu'à mes 17 ans et demi je n'ai eu
aucune aucune violence après c'est
toujours difficile de trouver sa place
dans une famille d'accueil surtout après
ce que j'avais vécu avant donc euh s
très bien passé je pense que je me suis
senti vraiment épanouie à partir moment
où où j'ai eu mon indépendance à mes
presque à mes 18 ans euh j'aiété prise
en charge ensuite par une association à
mes 17 ans et ils m'ont aidé à avoir un
logement audace audace c'est ça et je
remercie beaucoup éducatrice parce que
bravo bravo et il paraît que grâce à ton
témoignage à votre témoignage un enfant
a été sauvé oui
alors
euh avec mon placement dans ma première
famille d'accueil oui c'est ça oui oui
alors il y a le petit garçon qui a été
scotché autour de de l'arbre lorsque je
suis arrivée dans ma de FAM d'AC
j'ai averti je j'ai averti tout de suite
qu'il y avait ce petit garçon qui qui
est encore là-bas donc les services
sociaux sont intervenus à l'improviste
dans cette famille et et ont enlevé ont
remarqué que ça se passait mal et ont
enlevé le petit garçon la famille
d'accueil ont plus le droit de
travailler pour les l'aide sociale à
l'enfance du pas de calé mais ont pu
retravailler donc ils ont déménagé dans
le Nord et ont pu retravailler pour le
pour le
nordro ils ont juste déplacé ils ont
déplacé donc l'argent non mais c'est
c'est fou hein c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est incroyable cette his igile très
vite il y a quelque chose qui me qui me
sidè Sid j'ai discuté avec Nadia j'en
tremble j'en tremble il y a a Nadia elle
va mieux récemment elle a voulu porter
plainte elle a été porté plainte alors
vous allez nous raconter ça dans un
instant g parce que c'est l'histoire
vous allez voir ça continue c'est c'est
fou c'est c'est fou vous allez entendre
cette histoire chez vous qui est qui est
absolument incroyable Nadia restez avec
nous l'histoire de Nadia et Nadia il y a
que des messages sur toi sur les réseaux
qui sont incroyables et tous autour du
plateau là pendant la pause on se disait
que tu étais incroyable voà je me
permets de te tutoyer tu peux le faire
aussi he mais c'est vrai que tu es
incroyable tu as une histoire incroyable
et tu as une vraiment c'est c'est
incroyable sa façon de de raconter les
choses et sa dignité son son courage
franchement Nadia bravo et on est très
très heureux de
T' je dis tu sais c'est pr des
témoignages comme les tiens qu'on aime C
cette émission que j'aime faire cette
émission et que je fais encore cette
émission c'est vraiment voilà ça tu
resteras un des témoignages les les plus
importants de de de l'histoire de
l'émission je te le dis vraiment
vraiment euh on va on va reparler de
parce que ton histoire elle est elle est
incroyable donc tu été euh tu étais dans
une famille
d'accueil qui t'a fait subir des
services inadmissibles incroyables et
Gilles Verdez voulait raconter euh aux
téléspectateurs euh ce qui se passe
actuellement parce que c'est
fou vous allez vous dire chez vous là je
vous dis vous allez vous allez tous être
énervés ce soir donc Nadia on a vu de
l'âge de 3 ans l'âge de 10 ans elle a
subi des services graves dans une
famille d'accueil des services très très
graves qu'elle raconte aujourd'hui elle
s'est reconstruite elle va mieux
récemment elle se dit un acte salutaire
je vais aller porter plainte pour que ça
ne se reproduise plus que ces gens
soient sanctionnés et pour tous les
jeunes aussi qui sont des enfants martyr
et victimes de ses bourreaux d'enfants
elle va porter
plainte les gens qui la reçoivent
cherchent et dit oh là là mais ça c'est
rien c'est un délit délit c'est 6 ans
pour porter plainte c'est prescrit vous
ne pouvez pas porter plainte c'est
doublement scandaleux parce que la
prescription ne joue pas à priori on a
le droit de porter plainte donc on va y
retourner porter plainte vous allez de
nouveau aller porter plainte ce qui
s'est passé est inadmissible d'autre
part il y a pas de prescription parce
que pour moi là on est dans des tortures
et acte de barbarie sur mineurs
jusqu'elle raconte et ça c'est 20 ans
pour prescrire et ces gens-l ils
risquent que 30 ans donc la manière dont
elle a été traitée après tout ce qu'elle
a vécu par les autorités c'est
abominable pour moi c'est une deuxième
blessure qu'on lui inflige quand elle
m'a raconté ça j'ai dit mais Nadia c'est
pas possible c'est impossible ce qu'on
vous a fait comme vous dites souvent
cyil on marche sur la tête mais là c'est
c'est un avocat s TR voilà il faut que
vous soyez entendu parce que démarche on
peut vous aider
làdusag AC un avocat qui pe vous aider
la production et moimême oua avec un
avocat qui peut vous aider là-dessus
parce que c'est c'est vraiment c'est
important et il faut qu'on soit à vos
côtés et si vous avez besoin d'aide on
sera on sera bien sûr là pour vous aider
pour faire les démarches avec vous et
vous aider non parce qu'on sait que
c'est pas évident et que ça coûte
énormément d'argent voilà donc merci
beaucoup vous nous direz après voilà on
vous mettra en contact et on a on a
votre numéro mais on aimerait bien le
faire et assez rapidement parce que je
pense vraiment que c'est c'est comme a
dit Gill c'est une deuxième blessure et
surtout surtout ce qui est grave c'est
qu'on pense à oui aux autres enfants et
vous pensez actuellement mais ils sont
ils ont encore des ils sont encore
familles d'accueil là aujourd'hui ou pas
j'ai su il y a pas très longtemps qu'il
ne travaillaiit plus mais après moi ils
ont eu des nourrissons ils ont eu
ensuite des ados et après les ados
forcément ça se laisse pas faire donc il
y a eu des plaintes contre eux les ados
ont déposé des plaintes mais qui ont été
laissés sans suite et et ensuite jeai on
m'a une personne de leur famille est
revenu vers moi il y a quelques années
et elle m'a dit est-ce que si on te
contacte pour témoigner tu y vas h donc
moi je lui ai répondu oui même c'est ta
famille moi si on me contacte je vais y
aller bien après à cette période j'étais
pas encore assez prête pour moi me
lancer toute seule j'étais pas encore
j'étais pas encore bien pour le faire et
on m'a jamais contacté et lorsque
j'étais au commissariat pour déposer ma
plainte il y a la semaine dernière je
leur ai dit qu'il y avait eu des
plaintes contre eux et ils m'ont dit ah
de toute façon si c'était y a plusieurs
années on ne le verra
pas
incroyable alors il il paraît que vous
avez retrouvé votre petit frère
biologique grâce à un tweet oui il y a 1
an j'ai euh j'ai retrouvé mon petit
frère euh il a eu une chance d'adoption
il y a quelques années et euh j'ai posté
un tweet je me suis dit je me lance et
je voulais le retrouver et je voulais
créer un lien avec parce que moi j'ai
pas de lien j'ai des des frères mais
j'ai pas de lien avec eux et euh et mon
tweet a été relayé 16000 fois euh en
moins de 24 heures et grâce à mon tweet
c'est ça vous avez retrouvé j'ai reçu un
message de mon petit frère qui m'a écrit
c'est moi je suis là sous tes yeux ouais
et il était très contente de que j'ai
que je l'ai retrouvé que j'ai cherchéis
à reprendre contact avec lui mag oui
vous avez des contacts avec lui
maintenant ça y est je lui parle par
message mais des fois je sens que ses
parents je pense qu'ils ne sont pas
prêts à ce qu'ils reprennent un lien
avec avec un membre de sa vraie famille
après moi c'est ce que j'essaie
d'expliquer c'est que je suis dans la
même situation que lui au final j'ai
juste pas été adopté et moi j'ai été
tout autant séparé de de ma famille que
lui en fait c'est juste que moi j'ai été
en famille d'accueil et lui a été adopté
mais je pense que sa famille adoptive a
du mal à je peux comprendre ça doit
faire peur de de laisser son enfant
reprendre contact avec sa famille et tu
as tu as tu as des nouvelles de ta maman
biologique non du tout j'ai n plus de
nouvelle de ma mère depuis tes frères et
tes autres frères et sœurs non euh j'ai
pas plus de nouvelles que ça et moi j'ai
pas forcément envie de reprendre contact
voilà je je je veux pas c'est un peu
compliqué beaucoup de gens disent que
vous êtes
c'est
vrai c'est vraiiment on a le sentiment
que tu t'es reconstruit tout presque
toute seule c'est incroyable ton r
aujourd'i aujourd'hui jeis je suis
étudiante en 2e année de BTS analyse
biologique et
biotechnologique j'ai malheureusement
pas eu mon année donc je refais mon
année pas grave les
années voilà je B à 35 ans on s'en fout
franchement on s'en fout non mais c'est
vrai on s'en fout une fois que vous on
va pas vous demandz à quel âge vous avez
votre diplôme quand vous Erez en train
de travailler tranquille voilà
tranquille vous avez le temps j'espère
l'avoir cette année
après si je peux passer un message en
même temps je cherche une entreprise
j'ai malheureusement pas trouvé
d'entreprise en quoi dans le en
laboratoire laborato en alternance donc
là il me reste quelques jours pour
m'incrire en candidat libre si je trouve
pas d'entreprise alors en laboratoire je
connais pas je te cache pas que je suis
pas hyper calé en labo tu m'aurais dit
dans l'audiovisuel j'auraisurais dit
peut-être voilà je peutêtre faire peut
lancer un appel mais là
voà on appelle on peut appeler voilà ou
Mohamed Sanofi ou Rachid
priser les potes voilà si si voilà s'ils
peuvent faire quelque chose voilà merci
ça nous ferait du bien merci en tout cas
Nadia d'avoir été avec nous vous
continue à être
rayonante je je dis là je dis il faut
vraiment qu'on s'occupe de vous là
d'accord donc on va on va on va vraiment
vous aider sur ce qu'on s'est dit parce
que c'est important et c'est important
pour vous et si c'est important pour
vous c'est important pour nous et je
pense que toutes les personnes qui nous
regardent ont envie que voilà qui se
passe quelque chose parce que c'est
c'est pas possible de laisser ça comme
ça merci beaucoup merci Nadia merci
Nadia vous allez croiser raseradamus
dans le couloir c'estam
Palomba donc surtout ne lui parlez
pas ne la regardez pas dans les yeux non
mais je vous le dis voilà donc je non
mais je vous donne juste un conseil
voilà c'est quelqu'un qu'il faut voilà
il faut voilà il ne faut pas la croiser
voilà vraiment